Kezah ft. Freddy - Mirador
♫ (Mi amor) ♫
♫ Rio, Cancún, Marbella ♫
♫ Toi, moi, soleil, ma bella ♫
♫ Versace, Gucci, Margiela ♫
♫ J'ai la classe comme Manny Ribera ♫
♫ Cigarillo ♫
♫ Dans l'barrio ♫
♫ Parfum vanilla ♫
♫ Mucho dinero ♫
♫ J'l'ai juste invitée à dîner ♫
♫ Elle, dans sa tête, elle veut déjà se marier ♫
♫ Que du biff, que du biff, que du biff ♫
♫ Que la mif', que la mif', que la mif' ♫
♫ (Oh ouais) ♫
♫ Vol première classe pour Cuba ♫
♫ Escale à Puerto Rico ♫
♫ Je roule en Testarossa ♫
♫ Elle m'demande mon numéro ♫
♫ Mi amor, mi amor ♫
♫ Veut changement de décor ♫
♫ J't'ai vue d'puis l'mirador ♫
♫ Mettre la daronne à l'abri ♫
♫ J'donnerai tout pour ma famille ♫
♫ S'éloigner des ennemis ♫
♫ Faire plaisir à mon papi ♫
♫ J'veux la cuenta, la cuenta, la cuenta ♫
♫ Billet violet vient de Caramelo ♫
♫ Traficante toujours dans le bendo ♫
♫ Que du biff, que du biff, que du biff ♫
♫ Que la mif', que la mif', que la mif' ♫
♫ (Oh ouais) ♫
♫ Vol première classe pour Cuba ♫
♫ Escale à Puerto-Rico ♫
♫ Je roule en Testarossa ♫
♫ Elle m'demande mon numéro ♫
♫ Mi amor, mi amor ♫
♫ Veut changement de décor ♫
♫ J't'ai vue d'puis l'mirador ♫
♫ (Mi amor) ♫
♫ (J't'ai vue d'puis l'mirador) ♫
♫ Vol première classe pour Cuba ♫
♫ Escale à Puerto Rico ♫
♫ Je roule en Testarossa ♫
♫ Elle m'demande mon numéro ♫
♫ Mi amor, mi amor ♫
♫ Veut changement de décor ♫
♫ J't'ai vue d'puis l'mirador ♫
♫ (Mélodie) ♫
♫ (Mélodie n°2) ♫